welcome to this video playing Moscow
pollution I am always failing with the
pronunciation so I mean only I think you
place that that snake banner when you're
right yes the snake Ben Oni Wow if i
take F 694 that that is good hmm ok well
just look at it just looks a terribly
slow to play like that
interesting chan how to play here night
night over to c4 is definitely something
that makes sense i just wonder what the
right order of moose is now maybe start
with that i'm not quite sure maybe that
was what's to slow at it's difficult to
save at least it was difficult and
difficult for me check I don't think
that this is a good idea to be honest
how is he covering d6 and b6 no jack
whoa so 9 p-6 through k7 i also have the
immediate e5 or f4 or a4a i think evil
let's start with this not not be too
hasty and okay f4
do I go 85 or not probably not yet this
not quite sure where to put it
22 h 3 is also an idea okay i'm doing
this i'm not quite sure about if i
should but i'm taking too much time okay
next position is really really awful
here but you can screw it up by taking
too much time and I want to as usual try
to really to really really really really
refute it and just something normal
which just keeps the position great is
probably better because there are many
many continuations that just keep keep a
great advantage so look C 1 and B force
is great if I get it in I live down on
the clock
before it's already quite strong but um
it's okay he cannot really go b5 I take
it knight Knight takes Knight a5 496
you
tending before ok maybe after NAT ok
let's let's do it differently
before it's not really harmonious I
can't play would be 3 9 p-6 and putting
a rook on b6 is also pretty strong even
f5 is very much a consideration and it's
not a move you want to play this is
strong he takes that pawn takes a text
that bishop so it's a that's an
interesting move and I'm threatening g4g
four wins the bishop and he cannot take
them oh he actually can you actually can
hmm okay then then go there
no big deal now Bishop g4 also a Bishop
g4 would have been interesting then yeah
yeah that was that would have been
interesting so we can try to bluff him
into a no but I can go chief for now
right why not why am I not winning here
I don't see it okay i'ma show me and
that stands it mother Bishop Bishop f3
time morning take first him and then
Bishop f3 should be the peace
okay 30 seconds to check check childs in
need and meet check black resins made to
come okay yeah it was I don't really
believe that this is a playable position
from the opening it looks I don't know
you really play that check maybe Cui's
have not something that it looks I don't
know the engine just wants to take the
pawn i was a bit bluffing there i mean i
thought that i should have a great
compensation somehow but i didn't i
didn't really I didn't really try to
figure it out to a refutation or
something now it's probably just
compensation that the engineer stop
which gives white a small plus so it's
nothing to rush out check that end game
however is just fantastic four wide it's
just very very nice he five now I know
it's it's really a man I very one-sided
one-sided business yeah here before
already is interesting I wanted to
prepare it yeah but now I recognize that
before it's not really that great yeah
you can play this so so I mean it's
why this bid anyway here but it looks i
thought it's better to just play with
that rook b3 idea and now here playing
on that bishop is interesting yeah came
back I wanted to tempt him now here I he
ran into that g-form trap which
ultimately costs that bishop yeah I'd
seen that idea one or two moves earlier
that this was in the position and here
just do this apiece I'm gathered opening
seems seems wrong yeah I think maybe you
should castle I'm you're just
encouraging that with age 6 mm I don't
know I have this one though yeah I don't
know maybe I'm maybe I'm I'm wrong with
condemning condemning that's so very
weird word Condon anyway with
criticizing that maybe he's okay yeah
it's possible that's such a rare line I
never looked at it in any in any
reasonable detail well thanks for
watching